certains les revendique d'autres les dix
bafoué le secret de l'instruction et la
présomption d'innocence sont ils encore
bien vivant en france la question pose
le problème des relations parfois
difficiles entre la presse et la justice
les sénateurs se sont posé cette
question hier soir devant des avocats
des magistrats et des journalistes
également présents jean marie et
christine villemin acteur et témoin de
l'un des plus gros ratage judiciaire de
l'après guerre dominique verdeilhan
gilles dobler la commission depuis dix
ans christine et jean marie villemin se
disent victimes d'une catastrophe
judiciaire elle fut accusée à tort du
crime le plus atroce lui est en liberté
conditionnelle
dix ans de dérapages dix ans de douleur
est aujourd'hui une image plein de
symboles une poignée de main entre un
couple blessé par la justice et
l'actuelle garde des sceaux hier face
aux sénateurs
il songe une humilité pour le respect de
la présomption d'innocence
l'ensemble de la presse nationale et
régionale française a imaginé un grand
feuilleton en réécrivant mon histoire ma
jeunesse
notre vie de cook et même celle de notre
enfant que l'on disait entre autres
mal aimé si les gendarmes n'avaient pas
arrêté le premier inculpé devant les
caméras si le juge n'avait pas divulgué
les charges pesant sur lui si ses
avocats n'avaient pas fait jouer la
rumeur à son profit si les médias
n'avaient pas dit écrit c'est lui
l'assassin
si on avait compris notre désespoir et
sans minimiser sa responsabilité
on marie aurait-il assumer la mort
d'alors ainsi les villemin préconise
qu'on ne divulgue eu plus le nom d'une
personne placée en garde à vue et que
des sanctions soient prises quand la loi
est violée mais question la loi sol
peut-elle éviter un tel désastre
de toute façon selon christine villemin
pour le premier inculpé de la faire et
pour eux il est trop tard